don't watch the news decide when you
leave here today to make the news did
you don't get attention today you have
absolutely zero chance of being
successful money follows attention
period into story so you gonna make
mistakes in your life make them fast
right you're gonna lose a deal make them
lose the deal fast need motivation watch
the top 10 would believe nation
what's that believe nation it seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from coming out of a drug
rehab center at age 25 to 5 years later
becoming a millionaire and today owning
over a half a billion dollars in real
estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one success is your duty hey I
want to talk to you today about success
success Duty obligation responsibility
if you approach it any other way which
most people are most people think well
I'll be successful if the economy works
I'll be successful if something happens
I'll be successful if I win the lottery
ticket look you're not going to be
successful if you don't demand it if you
literally don't stake a claim to it and
say this is mine it's important you're
not gonna have it I promise you I know
I'm telling you from experience I spent
the first 25 years of my life like like
a spectator watching other people get
successful and then wondering why was it
success is your duty it is your
responsibility I'm sorry your obligation
and your responsibilities and pardon
rule number 2 make deals a priority
almost 90% of sales managers say they
don't have truck time you know and again
it goes back to look if you knew it was
gonna bank you money today would you
make time for it so they would they
would make time for it cuz they make
time for the things that make the money
if you if you have a customer hopefully
if you have a customer and you're
working to deal with that customer and
you got a hamburger in front of you
hopefully you're going to push the
hamburger aside and work that deal
because the priority is to make money on
in the same in the same conversation
that sales manager does not believe that
sales training converts to ROI or money
so he doesn't make the time for when you
say you don't have time it's the truth
is you're saying I'm not making it a
priority because I don't think it makes
me money rule number three work hard you
want to get your work ethic so high that
people actually admire you I'm gonna ask
you a question right now do people know
you because of your unbelievable work
ethic if you can't answer yes to that
man you're not going to get in that top
10% you got to get at the top you people
have to know you not because oh he's a
good salesman oh he's a good dish oh
he's an artist so he's a good pianist oh
he's a he writes a great you know story
no did people need to know you for one
major thing for
he works he produces the guys there
every day the guys pushing and shoving
because the truth is no matter how good
your ideas are how good your art is or
how good your skillset is if you're not
working man if you're not vibrating at a
frequency that people say my god how
does that guy do all that if you're not
vibrating at that rate 10x levels
massive action tremendous work ethic
that's just a muscle nowness it's just a
discipline in your life as a way it's a
normal way that other people think is
abnormal Ryan Seacrest Tom Cruise
Oprah's Steven Spielberg Donald Trump
still pumping and working as a
billionaire look if you're not working
at that level you're not gonna make it
get your work ethic in man it's the
American Way work ethic check it out
rule number four ignore the little man
the biggest struggle man was just
getting around other people that would
say I could do it I mean that's the
biggest struggle just you get around one
guy says yeah you can do it and then you
talk to him tomorrow and he's like
nowadays you know there's so few people
telling you to do it you know what there
is a lot of save your money
protect yourself conserve don't spin
don't take risk taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse so we're the
biggest struggle for me was my family
man the people closest to me was the
biggest struggle every time I went out
to do another deal everybody told me you
don't need to do that man the only
person that was encouraging me was my
twin brother because I would see how he
was doing it dude he was making his
swings and so every time I'd get around
other people so I'll tell you a little
trick I did on weekends I would always
go see Holmes I couldn't afford that has
always inspired me I would go look I
would go drive neighborhoods literally
I've done this my entire life until I
finally got to the point where they
wouldn't even let me in the neighborhood
there's neighborhoods in Miami do you
can't even go see you can they won't
even let you in the gates most of you
can get in if you know some of my tricks
so the point that show Vitas writing on
the board right now is you got fuel in
your tank
it wants to be accelerated on and then
you got somebody in the backseat saying
hey be careful
nobody likes a backseat driver okay
so they're sitting there they're putting
they're putting mental pressure on the
brakes when you're trying to accelerate
rule number five don't be negative the
negativity is just negative and there's
no money in it there's no future and
being negative where's the solution you
know I can't do that we can't do that
that can't happen this is wrong that's
wrong oh my gosh taxes are too high
taxes too dude it's negative it is
negative it is negative look there's so
much abundance of negativity that by
itself tells you why there's no value in
it rule number six have a target you got
to make a commitment to service you got
to make a commitment to like hey I have
a target I know that when we don't
achieve targets here in my office the
first thing I ask regardless the
internet department if it's my
accounting department on collections or
it's my sales department I'm gonna ask a
question what is the target
no target results in those sales so if
you're in parts if you're in service
look have a target measure that target
hourly if you really want to get results
measure your target every hour to see
what do we get in the last 60 minutes I
promise you do those two simple things
don't even learn anything about how to
sell anybody anything have a target
measure it every hour and I guarantee
your sales will come up rule number
seven don't depend on one product within
any company I have own I have four and
five flows in every company I don't have
one flow I'm not gonna depend on one
product once I get those four streams
coming in from one company okay for
instance at this company it's a it's an
online project called Cardone University
then they're speaking gigs then there's
books then there's audios there's mp3s
those are flows coming in for one
company at some point I'm like okay
let's do a second deal so I'm gonna then
have a company that runs parallel like a
skier right I don't want their skis
crossing over I want it to be parallel
so that anything that maybe I can't do
any longer in this company maybe I'm
gonna outsource to a partner and build a
second company then once these two are
skiing along and happy maybe I'm
do a third company out here that I have
a passion for that has nothing to do
with these first two that is not
diversification that's multiple strong
flows and when I make a bet on this
third company do not want to take it I
want to take all the money from these
first two flows and I want to say hey if
it's a good deal go all-in if you're not
sure don't put any money in it at all
folks rule number eight my personal
favorite believe you know I mean there's
so many mistakes salespeople make I
think you need to get down to like the
the main ones but you're not selling the
solution I mean even before that though
I would say Corinne is the biggest
mistake people are not excited they're
not alive they're not they're not
showing interest in the cycle and they
lose interest I was in Barcelona
recently and I was looking at a watch
and the cycle didn't didn't close I
could have bought the watch I was
qualified to buy the watch I'm the one
that walked myself in the shop on my
vacation to look at the watch I know
exactly the watch I was looking for and
when I left my wife said what could he
have done to close the sale I said well
he could have kept a life in the cycle
he could have kept the cycle open so
what I mean by that is look if you're
not interested if you don't believe the
cycle can be closed it will not close so
the number one mistake I think
salespeople managers and the store makes
is they assume a closed can't be had
that day I go into every cycle every
sales cycle with every prospect every
phone call every no matter how complex
the sale is or how simple it is with the
belief that I can sell that product that
day this time now rule number nine work
to your potential hey work to your
potential not your quota if you want to
stay really motivated if you want to
answer the question - why people that
have already made it keep pushing it is
because they don't operate on quotas
they operate off potential they're
driven to reach their potential this is
also tied to their ethical obligation
they know what they're capable of nobody
can tell you what you're capable of
you're the only one that knows okay so
work to your potential not your
Moda quotas are numbers who made them up
some guy says okay your quota is blah
blah okay
based on what how do you come up with
that quota he only picked that quota
that number because he thinks is
significant are compared to other people
maybe in your industry
look don't operate on quotas you want
them clearly you want them but you want
to be driven to reach your potential not
just some number some mechanics hey my
potential I know nobody else knows that
I know what it is you know yours work to
your potential not just a quota and I
promise you you will be on fire
day and night rule number ten don't quit
hey grant cardone I just want to give
you a little encouragement here on
Thursday afternoon this week I have been
in Detroit Buffalo New York City I was
on my way to Hartford it got cancelled
because of some situations whoa I just
dropped my back why am I telling you all
this okay now I came to the wrong
terminal I'm gonna walk back to - I'm
not asking you to feel sorry for me I'm
doing this as an encouragement video
dude things don't go right you gotta
push harder you got to spend money that
you didn't think you were gonna spend
hang in there don't quit do not quit
push
okay I know how hard it is I know it's
hard I know there's moments where your
everybody thinks oh my god what am i
doing just keep pushing your family
needs you to do it you can even you need
to do it god Bless America it definitely
needs you to do it so hang in there keep
pushing when you think about quitting
just understand that everybody you
complete with is having the very same
thought last-man-standing baby rule
number 11 be obsessed I hear a lot of
guys saying right now like hey only do
the things you want to do dude I do
stuff I don't want to do every single
day okay so I don't know who these
people are that don't do the things they
don't want to do maybe they were given a
business or something but I'm gonna tell
you something man if you don't do the
things you don't want to do you're not
gonna grow your business you won't keep
your business I'm telling you you have
to be willing to do you got to be so
obsessed that you don't collect care see
an obsessed person doesn't care if they
have to clean a toilet uh-huh you know
an obsessed person doesn't care if they
if they don't like that activity but
they have to do it
you're obsessed you're in it you do it
anyway no matter what I remember my mom
told me one day she's like you know
grant I love you just the way you are
because I tell I'm telling her about all
these dreams I have as a child right
yeah and I was reminded when my sister
told me like 30 years later you know
grant you've done a lot we love you just
the way you are and I'm like dude I
wonder how many times I've been told
that you know and the fact is so what
they love me just the way I am I don't I
don't love me just the way I am which
opens up to this whole field of people
that's like just love yourself the way
you are look if you're broke you're not
living on purpose you don't like your
job you can't get away from your job
dude if you're stuck in a house you
don't like why would you want to love
that you should become obsessed with
hating it man it's obsessed or average
one of the two so pick just pick get a
t-shirt obsessed or get another t-shirt
average which one would you be more
proud wearing right
who do I want to be man who do I want to
be how do i how do I want to die man I
want to die all in rule number 12
go for it here's the deal guy just hit
me on snapchat and said hey man I'm
going for it cuz I only got one life to
live and I can I and I snapped him back
and just said hey man what if that one
life thing isn't true bro and he's not
now he's wondering is that what you mean
man what you mean I said well here's the
deal okay I mean you don't know and I
don't know right I mean maybe you don't
know maybe I do but here's the deal I'm
much more dangerous and much more of a
risk taker and much more a going all the
way dude and less introverted when I'm
not worried about the one life myth okay
I'm thinking hey baby what if I live
forever man then am I willing to take
the risk
am I willing to make the sales call see
me living forever
the immortality concept makes me way
dangerous
makes me sick dangerous makes me crazy
okay it makes me want to go for it every
freaking single day because I don't have
the ultimate to lose you understand what
I'm saying hey check it out maybe you
know maybe you don't know but I'll bet
you're curious what if you live forever
what if this is like a thousand town
what have you got a thousand more runs
at this deal well then go for it bottom
line is one life or many lives go for it
today go for it in a big way and go for
it like you gonna live it forever
rule number 13 learn to dominate look if
you want to be in business for yourself
and free you must learn to dominate you
cannot compete okay how many were
trained this competition is a healthy
thing that message was not being
delivered to entrepreneurs that message
was being delivered to consumers there
was somebody saying look the more more
oil companies we have the better because
it's good for the customer right the
more technology companies we have is not
just Microsoft
the better for the customer and into
Vivian inventions and you know
improvements and products comes from
competition but if you're the one
playing the game you want to dominate
the field so look here's the deal I
might be wrong and what I say okay I
might be wrong in the things I do in my
life and the business that I started my
family's told me not to start every
business that I've been involved in
every one of them every one of them was
a risk everyone on my hand had shake
take a chance I remember my mom used to
tell me I wouldn't do that if I were you
I wouldn't do that if I were you I
wouldn't do that if I were you I'm like
mommy you wouldn't do anything well you
wouldn't do anything except be the
mother a great mother to five children
my mother was an entrepreneur she didn't
have my dreams just because she's my mom
doesn't mean she dreams like me would
you agree okay my mom was wrong about
everything she told me not today love my
mom to death okay unbelievable friend of
mine she was wrong I needed to do those
things okay
Steve Jobs needed to build this phone
would you agree did he help a lot of
people did he make some money while he
was doing it 119 billion dollars in five
years in the bank cash I'm not talking
about probably I'm talking about in the
in done in the bank sitting there okay
brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination total domination okay X on
the total domination you see what I'm
saying you want to be in a dominating
point okay so what we got to do is we
got to get you thinkin we got to get you
thinking like the dominators think how
did they act how does Warren Buffett act
what does Warren Buffett do with his
time all the time those are the people I
study today I don't study the people
that I went to school with the teachers
I went to school with
I don't even study my own family members
okay I'm looking for people that are way
up here that I could say hey what are
they doing because they're doing it
right rule number 14
control your thoughts I know that one of
the key things one of the things that's
made me successful in my life is making
it a priority to control
my thoughts like what am I thinking
about like literally putting discipline
in on how I talk to myself and so I
don't want this to sound all the
psychobabble stuff it's not like it's
not like oh if you just stand in the
mirror and talk to yourself to say
positive things everything's gonna be
all right that's not true be careful
what you say to yourself okay because if
you're saying a $30 steak is a lot of
money or a $4 toy is a lot of money when
your kid wants a $4 toy listen to what
you're saying that's a lot of money
three to four dollars is a lot of money
okay oh my worst day four dollars has
not been a lot of money even though okay
I've been at periods in my life where I
didn't have $4 so I'm talking to you
today about how do you control how do
you control how do you discipline how do
you stop monitoring what you're saying
to yourself I can't find the right girl
I can't find the right guy there's no
good guys left in this town all men are
pigs women cheat on their men a marriage
is hard having kids is difficult I don't
want to pay taxes you know I can't help
myself
I can't stop I can't trust myself I
never do what I say I procrastinate I'm
an introvert I'm broke I'm poor so look
what are you saying to yourself all the
time the first thing I did was I took up
I took a little journal Allen and I just
wrote down all the negative things I say
to myself by the way I just gave you the
list okay I can't spend money I can't
save enough money I don't make enough
money okay I don't know how to invest in
the stock market
I can't invest in real estate I don't
have time to do this you know the time
thing people just kill themselves for
the time thing I don't have enough time
I don't have enough time I don't
enough Tom guess what oops
you don't have enough time you don't
have time you don't have money
catch yourself every time you say I
don't have time say hey I create time
every time you say I know have money I
create money or maybe just start just
start literally like talking to yourself
that hey I am a millionaire I am a
multi-millionaire own if you want if
you're in the apartment game and you
want to be in apartments but you don't
know anything about apartments you could
start literally talking to yourself
saying I am worth around 100 units I did
this for years for years before I ever
bought an apartment
I used to write down I own 20 apartments
that owns 12% cash flow Iren over and
over I bet I bet I wrote this down a
thousand times I own 20 apartments my
first deal was 38 units I own 20
apartments or more and I write it in any
little journal any piece of paper any
legal pad every time you say something
negative write down I need to lose
weight okay that's good but you know if
you're running a race you don't say I
need to finish the race you're like
you're looking for that you're you got a
run right you got a run you got to move
you got to keep moving your feet so I
mean you can sit there say I got to
finish this race but the truth is if you
need to lose weight man just once you
pick your target weight and start
affirming
I weigh 165 pounds I weigh 165 pounds so
just switch it a little bit right all
you're trying to do is discipline you're
trying to move the river so if you're
broke right now quit saying I am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going
rule number 15 you got to get some
haters you need haters no school is
gonna teach you how to get a hater okay
high school elementary school colleges
what do they teach you want to be the
most popular person now you want haters
okay the companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding the
people that are hated are the people
that explode if I don't hate you if
nobody hates you nobody knows you so the
reason I'll tweet for instance when we
we had this that newsletter that I sent
out okay we send it out every week we
were hitting people once a month and we
started getting complaints you send
stuff out too much my office came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have more people pulling off of the
newsletter good double up again why I
want haters okay so we start sending out
one every week and then I started
Twitter account I actually had people
write grant cardone
social media people Grant Cardone is an
example of what not to do with social
media
I said freaking just multiply just
increase it okay we were doing like four
tweets a day good due to an hour why
because I want my competition hating my
guts someone I'm talking about me I mean
I don't really want hate people to hate
me you understand what I'm saying about
I want them so so energized that they
actually start pushing me they start
promoting me rule number 16 decide to
make the news I use every one of the
news channels if you'll see me on TV
doing news one day okay
i don't i don't watch news i make news
see the shift you see the slight shift
don't watch the news decide when you
leave here today to make the news right
you don't read the newspaper you write
newspaper articles you don't read books
ya read them but learn to write them and
you know that you don't need to take for
it you don't need to spend a lifetime
right in the book this was three hours
okay we still 40,000 copies of this one
book and it was self-published it's
never ever ever been in a bookstore a
guy writes me says and you got
misspelled words all in that book
I'm like yeah yeah what so what where
are they 123 128 134 165 120 I'm like
yeah yeah and bad grammar - I'm like
yeah what's your point dude I don't know
what's your point man why do you keep
telling me that he's right cuz man you
got misspelled worked in a book it's a
best-seller
[Music]
okay so we did a best-written okay you
know what I'm not now this war just sew
in nobody under I don't want you to
think that that's a cuss word the word
look it up in the dictionary means a
complain or a whine or an excuse maker I
wear a little ban on my pin here on my
wrist here it's a little black band and
it says champions dominate and on the
other side don't be a little bit that's
right because I don't need it I need to
get rid of the whiners the excuse makers
oh my god is to market it's the market
of my prices how are we inventory okay
now let's go there's too much inventory
now - a little inventory you human
beings have so many excuses this is
unbelievable you know why because you
watch the news too much because you've
agreed to receive news not make news
rule number 17 get advice from the right
people my journal is a professor said
the money will come follow your heart
follow your passion the money will come
that's what was told to me and he knew
nothing about money otherwise he
wouldn't have been in his job he should
not have been giving you advice on money
he doesn't have any money you got people
but if his measurement of success is not
money and it's been why he would buy so
money that's my point
my dad my dad died when he was 52 okay
he made it in the middle class my mom
and my dad thought they had made it when
the truth is the next week my mom had to
sell the house he had bought so we could
live that is not making it okay you
should not get your advice from people
in the middle class about finances they
don't know anything about finances
rule number 18 get busy if you know what
day it is you are not busy enough I
recently heard this week
oh it's Monday man it's so hard to get
started on a Monday I'm like that how do
you even know it's Monday I don't know
what day it is
on Wednesday we hear it's humpback day
we're halfway there so it's Friday and
it's like
oh thank God it's Friday or follow
Friday or like dude how do you people
know what day it is you're not busy
enough you need to be so freaking busy
that you don't know what time it is you
don't know if it's before lunch after
lunch before dinner after dinner come on
you've had those productive days
remember the day when you were so
productive you you literally work
through lunch and dinner and you looked
up at seven o'clock you should have been
home an hour ago and you're like did I
haven't had lunch or dinner you know why
because that day you were eating the
marketplace you were consuming the
marketplace because you were active
productive hitting it slamming creative
and completely committed look that's
where you need to be today look I don't
know what Monday Wednesday or Friday are
I don't know about Saturdays and Sundays
I know this create tremendous amount of
activity so much activity that you lose
track of time your success is not gonna
come from watching TV or looking at a
calendar your success is gonna come from
activity from being busy from being
obsessed from being like so into it that
you don't know about oh my gosh the
Monday morning blues or Wednesday hump
back or Friday what Friday what whatever
okay get busy
rule number 19 show up no matter what at
different places in life I promise you
you're gonna find you don't know where
to go everybody goes through this the
most successful people in the world wake
up some mornings with no clue what to do
today okay
so first thing I want you to know is
that it's normal it happens to everybody
it's not like you're a bad person or
you're lost or you're depressed or you
got some problem you need to take
medication for everybody everybody
regardless their stature in life where
they are regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint promise you
no matter how much they present like
they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody everybody
has those days and the Sun is kickin
today has those days where they don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
you know uncertainty my friend Dale
Christiansen told me when I was 25 years
old experiencing depression every day
he's like no matter what man no matter
what no matter what dudes show up even
if your eyes are bleeding show up I've
been doing that for 34 years now show up
even when I don't want to okay and then
what I try to do is I try to help one
person one person and what happened over
the period of 34 years I did that every
day I'm not depressed anymore
at least not for long periods of time I
don't use any kind of medication don't
use any kind of drugs don't smoke we
don't drink over excessively drink I
might have a drink once in a while and
got a beautiful wife two beautiful kids
and for the most part of my life that's
frickin wonderful all I did was this
I don't overanalyze never do i label
myself a loser
a quitter I'm hard on myself I never I
never labeled myself OCD a CD a DD OCD D
whatever a depressant alcohol like a
drug addict no no I don't this is what I
do I do things okay show up move in the
direction I don't overanalyze move in
the direction that that I think could be
more pro-survival than staying in one
place and number three help somebody
rule number 20 help somebody
[Music]
let me get that for you let me get that
you know my mission
no in any solution if they give me a
movie star yeah - if our muscles man
[Music]
hello do he get back in the round ready
bird awake over there I gotta get back
in the rear end okay I thought about
that thank you
the first somebody to help me is people
all over this planet man just lost lost
look here my boy right here what's going
on man yes 10 bucks
my man's working you're not drinking
that right
[Music]
history
while we do this
while we may get 100 thank you and you
keep it Thank You boss you do man huh
what do you do I work at McDonald's
awesome man awesome man you got a wife
no I don't you got kids no you got a mom
yes
give him some of that all right thank
you I hope not you ain't using drugs no
no you don't drink good man thank you
where you from man were you from
Minnesota
before that where's your family from
China thank you thank you somebody man
somebody I know you want to do that
everybody wants to do that everybody
wants to be the guy
it helps somebody out a random dude I
don't even know his name
I'm from MIT Mike from minnesota's they
made Mike and he ain't from Minnesota
come on let's keep it real
well you know what his days different
today you see a big smile on his face
when I did that just like pop help
somebody
rule number 21 put yourself first
my dreams are first everyday then my
wife then my kids I could take care of
my wife and my kids now would you agree
I abandoned this this is the fuel for
Who I am I abandon this dream and then I
end up I can't take care of them and
then I'm gonna tell them what it's
alright that you didn't win no it's not
alright if you don't win you need to win
how many of you need to win more okay if
you don't control your environment folks
somebody else is going to control your
environment you guys have run teams and
run organizations if you do not control
your environment someone else will
control your environment you are being
controlled in your environment right now
CNBC CNN MSNBC the parents the kids the
Twitter the Facebook the YouTube the
Google the snapchats are your
environment your friends and your
relatives your uncle's your aunts the
garbage dump called planet Earth that
you live on is mostly broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with me when I was 45 years old
I'm like I'm gonna control my
environment I'm gonna take every penny I
have all the energy I have all the
resources I have and I'm gonna improve
me if I got to go broke in the process
because I'm already broke look if you're
not fulfilled - you're if you're not
reaching your full potential every day
you're broke right now
rule number 22 get attention how many of
your parents told you this don't get too
much attention fly under the radar don't
toot your own horn be seen and not heard
dude you don't get attention today you
have absolutely zero chance of being
successful money follows attention
period in the story you guys that don't
have time for Facebook and Twitter and
snapchat and Instagram you're like I
ain't got time for all of that how many
said that before you like ain't got time
for all that bullsh I'm busy being broke
I'm busy I'm busy running my head into
the ground I'm busy I'm busy freaking
with a bunch of old lies and old ideas
I'm busy paying for my house note for
the next 27 years stuck in one place and
I can't move two jobs
rule number 23 keep feeding the dream I
know everybody's looking for hey when
did your life change look at changes
every day so and then and then you got
to add change on top of that how are you
gonna get to Mars right well you're
gonna build a ship you're gonna probably
blow up the first two or three of them
and then you're gonna stay focused on
the task get people around you that
don't make excuses get rid of people
that do and then you're gonna be like
hey we're going to Mars dude no matter
what it takes what it cost and you got
to keep feeding the dream you know and
so that's what I've done dude I like
from eight years old like eight seven
eight years old I've just been feeding
the beast and when I quit feeding the
beast of my dreams and fantasies when I
quit giving them energy what happened
was I started feeding other demons and
and my my life went downhill so by the
time I'm 25 I'm broke I'm wrecked I'm
spiritually bankrupt I'm physically
bankrupt I hate myself and then but I
didn't quit you know
I just had to start rebuilding from zero
rule number 24 don't make excuses
hey I was broke do you understand I was
broke when I was 25 dead broke I'm not
talking about financially broke let me
tell you something no I didn't have any
money in my pocket I didn't have any
credit cards nobody would give me credit
okay didn't have a driver's license okay
1970 Ford Maverick had a 1970 Ford
Maverick no air no heat no door handles
the freakin floor was rusted okay I
lived in a 275 square foot apartment
maybe 300 square feet if he counted a
little step out in the front of the
front door Bay to 75 a month and I was
late almost every month
so don't tell me about you money
problems man okay don't tell me about
where you were born
don't tell me about your bad brakes
don't tell me about what your daddy did
or your uncle felt you up or something
just some kind of weird thing to you
know I'll ruin your head or your sister
abused you or whatever okay look we all
got problems you got to fix your
problems now you got to get your money
right so 25 years old online I'm getting
my money right I'm done no more excuses
no more crybaby no more blame I'm
getting my freakin money right rule
number 25 study success as I started
studying people that did more now people
that didn't do more not people that said
do less not people that said hey don't
be satisfied or be satisfied not people
that said they'd be grateful for what
you have I started studying people that
said and had done more that you can do
more that's who I listen to today I
listened to the people aren't my friends
in my life the people I listen to the
people I've talked to you the people
that I follow on Facebook or YouTube or
Instagram
I don't follow everybody I follow the
people that say you can do more dude I
follow the people that say I am doing
more I follow the people that are
actually doing something on this planet
to make a difference for the better you
have to be selective you have to give
something up okay you cannot listen to
everybody to every voice
- every person is quit or given up you
got to make a decision if you have that
little voice inside of you that says you
can do more you have to give attention
to that voice and you got to feed it
with those that support that idea that
you can do more
rule number 26 work super hard I
remember my dad my dad died when I was
10 years old he didn't have a problem
with work he said work is good he said
more work is better
he said lots of work is even better than
that and if you could get a whole bunch
of people working together you could
actually accomplish something now fast
forward you know to to somewhere in the
last 20 years work became an addiction
like oh my god your work addict you're a
compulsive work person you're over
achiever you have problems in your life
I'm like dude the only problem I got in
my life is that you telling me work is a
bad bad thing the more I work the better
I am the more I get accomplished the
happier I am the more I work in a more
accomplished the better I feel about
myself I'm not trying to fill up a hole
I'm trying to get my reach my potential
rule number 27 expand okay check this
out 22 out of 28 million small
businesses in America have no employees
zero employees what kind of business is
that man I am the master and the slave I
am the prisoner the warden the jailhouse
the system that you're stuck that's not
a business you cannot do the solopreneur
thing even though you see some guy on
Instagram rollin out with a Lambo okay
it's [ __ ] that's not a business a
business is people in a company anybody
know any major successful person that
didn't have a bunch of employees
anybody here know any great company that
had one employee one flow of income that
didn't use debt okay
caterpillar debt coca-cola debt Ford
Motor Company debt they had to use debt
you gotta use debt to expand you can't
stay small and expect the world to know
you it's impossible rule number 28 aim
for freedom for Mason
cesses is freedom like the end of the
day I want freedom my money's great but
money just gets us freedom right so I
see a lot of my peers in fact a friend
that I was doing business with a couple
years ago he said to me as I grant your
the freest guy I know this guy's
extremely wealthy
we're multi billions of dollars he says
you my friend are the freest guy I know
so what do you mean by that just came
out of nowhere you say what you we'd
spent a lot of time together he's like
I've been with you now for about a month
and a half you say what you want you do
what you want you know there's gonna be
consequences
it's clear that you're consciously aware
that you're saying something that it's
gonna affect somebody he's like you're
not stupid you know what you're doing I
see you on YouTube Facebook Twitter
Instagram snapchat he didn't even know
what most of these was he said he says I
see you say what you want as often as
you want willing to make mistakes she
sees it too right so she knows that we
go into an environments and she's gotten
even used to the fact that I'm gonna
have my opinion I'm gonna go research
things that other people might find
controversial I'm gonna dig into things
that people are like saying no about
well across the line so for me it's
about freedom it's about can I go where
I want can I do business with you I want
this is what I've always wanted in my
life I want to go where I want I don't
want to be fixed in one spot I want to
be able to move rule number 29 go to the
next level my first 10 years of my life
I remember going being on one plane with
my mom my dad and my brothers and
sisters we went on one trip in ten years
before that we know I never did I've
never been on a trip we sat in coach and
we flew to Los Angeles and we went to
Disneyland
okay and every time we were every time
we looked at something everything was
too expensive so and I was tripping out
all I knew was the people that had the
money had the control they decided when
we went to the Mickey Mouse pancakes
shop what rides we could be on and and
you know fast forward to today you know
I know I don't stand in line when I go
to Disneyland I'm like hey what do I
have to pay so I don't have to stand in
line my dad could have probably
that too but he wasn't he didn't go to
the next level and and for him for my
parents you know you made money you
saved money you protected money and that
was good but but it's not the only
solution my dad stopped at save the
money and let's go on a trip you know
rather than hey you know what let's keep
building
let's keep growing let's be obsessed
with something monster not just enough
and and because my dad was satisfied
with enough he died at 52 I don't know
maybe he died at 52 the other way too
but when you scale out dude you can
actually live longer because you're not
doing all the work anymore
rule number 30 set the right target what
do you not know about money you need to
ask yourself that what is that you don't
know about money you live on a planet
that has endless amounts of paper you
have plenty of sticky sticky note pads
everybody agree with that I mean how
many of your shard on legal pads or our
sticky notes are ear swabs or cotton
swabs not shorter than any of that stuff
everybody everybody has plenty of that
stuff except maybe the people in Puerto
Rico that by the way that's a good
example of what can happen to good
people bad things happen to good people
and money money solves some of those bad
things from happening to them would you
agree okay now if you didn't leave
Puerto Rico and you knew a cat5 storm
was coming or Mo was coming to Utah to
Florida or Harvey was coming to Houston
right or you live in Los Angeles and you
know there's earthquakes and you don't
have a plan
what is it you don't know like like
you're not stupid you're not dumb and
you're not lazy you're a bunch of
entrepreneurs in a room they want to do
something big you would not come to this
conference if you did not want to scale
your business the question was asked the
other night why do you want to scale you
all have to scale you have to scale for
this one reason right you need money you
need money okay why do I need money what
don't I know about money why are people
struggling with money you should ask
yourself these questions why are you
coming up short on money is that what
you know or what you don't know how many
of you know they're saying knowledge is
okay yeah how many of you agree with
that how many agree knowledge is power
so look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge could the wrong knowledge be
power over you right see what I'm saying
so like when you set your business up
how many of you set your business up you
know about the average entrepreneur solo
firm implement or makes about 42,000
bucks a year and the average American
makes 58 this guy left a job to make
less money so he could say hey I'll work
for myself me and Gary Vaynerchuk had
this conversation
he's like looked somebody's better off
making 42 for themselves and making 42
for somebody else I said dude ain't
nobody better off making 42
okay so you see this is what you need to
understand the first thing you've got is
you got to decide now Sean says he
doesn't chase a number I chasing a
number why would you have a target on
everything in life and not have one on
money every athlete has a target right
every professional has a target every
department and every company every
division I have has a target no target
means what what is your target right if
I have no target I'm successful I will
hit the zero target
okay guys homeless out there hey begging
for food can you give me some food can
you give me some food I give him food
he's like no no no I don't really want
the food I really want to just say it on
the sign bro you be 100 just change the
ask but you gotta have a target you
gotta have Atari rule number 31 be
willing to pay the price this is the
secret of the successful people this is
what I've committed my life to do it I
told my mom when I was 16 years old one
day one day I'm gonna be successful one
day one day I'm gonna be successful and
one day I'm gonna help a lot of people I
always say this pay the price today so
you could pay any price in the future
pay the price now okay pay the price my
buddies were traveling seeing the world
and I didn't have any of those
experiences I've had people tell me
hey you market too much you market too
aggressively take me off your list my
office tells me we hit the list too much
I'm like what's a list far hit the less
that's what it's for your stay 8 8 8
billion people on planet Earth
look I've been ridiculed by my peers by
customers and by competition I've been
judged for working too much wanting too
much being too colorful being
inappropriate insensitive and too out
there
I'm trying to figure it out I've been
threatened I've been sued I've been
betrayed by friends I've been ripped off
and I've been copied 30 years 30 years
18-hour days I'm not eight-hour days not
10-hour days not 12-hour days 18-hour
days it's been 30 years 30 years it's
probably gonna be 30 years for you to
doubt uncertainty insecurities rejection
disappointment judgment it's gonna be 30
years of it are you willing to pay the
price
are you willing to pay the price if
anybody thinks you're gonna be
successful without paying that price
you're wrong rule number 32 meet the
world head-on you got to get up you got
to get out the amount of time you spend
outside your proximity or location where
you sleep gives you a better chance of
being successful so get up get out go
meet the world head on folks no matter
how bad it is okay you got you got
reputation problems you got
I feel bad problems you got friend
problems you got money problems whatever
the problems are okay try this just get
up and get out
go meet the world head on go meet
whatever it is okay you got to make up
to somebody you got to apologize for
something you've done you got to make up
by the damage of of years of neglect and
maybe betrayal and look I've done all
that I've had all those things where I
screwed up over and over and over again
my reputation sucked I was 20 between
the ages of 15 and 25 years old it was
like I was doing everything I could just
to damage damage my reputation okay if
it made me look bad I did it so here
today I'm gonna spend ten days 14 days
something like that up here with that
view you can fix anything I'm proof that
you can fix anything
anything can be fixed anything can be
fixed but you got to fix it you got to
fix it you can't just sweep it under the
old rug you got to fix it you got to
clean up the damage you got to pay the
price
clean up your debts do what you say
you're gonna do become the most
dependable person in your space come to
go to person oh I can put that person on
stage and know exactly what they're
gonna get for me I can put that person
in the game and I know what play they're
gonna run I can put that person on the
floor and I know they're gonna get it
done be the go-to person okay you don't
need to be funny
you don't need to be entertaining all
the time you don't need to be the person
or talking about you need to be the
go-to person folks
rule number 33 commit fully so you gonna
make mistakes in you like make them fast
right you're gonna lose a deal make them
lose the deal faster you're not gonna
make any money on the deal make sure the
deal is quick right how many made no
money on the deal this month but it took
four hours you see most of you in the
room unfortunately you listen to the
media so much you think you're you think
you're you're everything's good you
think you're fine okay because the media
has not expose the reality on the
middle-class they talk about poverty and
they talk about the rich people and they
never talk about the people in between
the people in between in this country
suffer more than the people in poverty
people in poverty are actually taking
care of people in the middle are
completely ignored I'm talking about the
people that make 200 grand a year and
live up here and still don't have any
money left over
they send their kids to school they got
two BMWs they live in a nice house they
have air conditioned water and heat
right and there's some money so they
send a little bit money to a Keo account
and they think okay we're gonna retire
one day you put me whole one day by the
time you get to use that money you'll be
sold you won't want to use it the only
thing that's gonna change anything for
you and your family is like what am I
doing here okay you don't need to go
work in another industry you take the
habit you have right now to the
restaurant business the restaurant
business will fail every business is in
disruption right now everything they say
you want to go do you want to go trade
Bitcoin it's gonna take a commitment
it's gonna take ups and downs gonna be a
bunch ups and downs in that crypto play
everybody great okay you want to go do
the real estate game rather than a card
game I'm gonna tell you something right
now man if you don't bring commitment
and discipline and and and fortitude and
persistence in a real estate game you
will get killed in the real estate game
there's no game that you're gonna win at
it doesn't require commitment
rule number 34 be courageous single
biggest mistake I've made in my career
was not spending money
it's what put me in a position to be
able to buy real estate because I had
money but I had to buy the real estate I
had to use the money Bradley made a
comment the other day about money money
is not to be saved and hoarded like like
it's no good if you don't use it this is
the problem with Bitcoin when did when
do I transact with it right I'm sitting
on a million dollars with a Bitcoin
right now I can't get rid of it fast
enough I can't go buy stuff with it so
until that that that situation is
resolved
right it's why people don't hoard gold
anymore you don't keep gold because you
can't exchange money is to be used for
those of you out there that are like
complaining about the cost of anything
the truth is that's what that money's
for the only thing the only purpose
money has is to be used and and I was
scared that I couldn't produce more
money so every time I spent money I
complained about it today I'm like
that's the biggest mistake I ever made
should have been spending more money it
wouldn't it taken taken me 30 years in
the first five years I should have
borrowed money I didn't have and I
should have spent money than I did have
and I should have gone into debt to do
it to get my brand out there to get it
known the mattress kind your town did it
the car guy in your town did it whoever
spent the most money whoever whoever put
it all out there all the time every day
on every TV radio and the internet wins
in the battle it's not the prettiest guy
okay
[Music]
it's not it's the guy that out advertise
that out spin Xie it takes courage to
make money
rule number 35 don't keep your mind wide
open take a quick a quick note out to
all of you out there that believe that
an open mind is important which by the
way I agree with you I agree an open
mind is important you know the old
saying the mind is like a parachute it
won't work if it's open but I want you
to add one piece to that if that
parachute is wide open you've fallen
straight to the ground you understand
what I'm saying if it doesn't open if
the mind doesn't open you're in trouble
if it opens too wide you're dead man
bouncing or a dead woman balancing my
point of view is this okay most people
do actually have an open mind the
problem is many people they have a mind
that's wide open with no filters no
gates no protection you listen to
everyone you listen to everyone on
Facebook everyone on Instagram you
listen to your uncle your aunt your mom
your dad when the minds to open you get
too much data and you go into confusion
rule number 36 work in a team how
important is it to have that team and
and to all those who are watching that
are starting out their teams what would
be the advice that you would give them
yeah well the the whole solopreneur
thing I'm gonna do it by myself I'm
gonna work from home that's it's not
even real like I know it's popular you
see it on Instagram and you think some
guys doing something on Instagram but
he's not doing anything posted he posted
an image of his car that he watches on
Instagram okay okay it might not even be
his car by the way
okay he's rubbing out his car and posted
somebody else's car he posted a picture
of Edmond's car as he passed up here in
the heel so after he freakin mowed my
lawn so what would I tell you dude you
got to be on a team I mean like like how
are you going anyplace by yourself you
live on a planet with 7 billion people
you're like I hear people say all the
time I don't I you know I'm an X I'm an
introvert and I don't like people do you
live on planet Earth right ok kind of
the wrong place to intro
so you know people I know people that
can't swim I'm like two-thirds of the
planet is water hey jump in this boat I
might want to get your stroke zone no I
mean there's a chance in your life and
that you're going to need people and you
might need a back stroke right you night
might need to go the whole your breath
is that boy so so like I don't
understand why people aren't getting
prepared we live on a planet that is
basically it's got gravity on it it's
got an atmosphere and there's one common
thing whether you're Chinese Hispanic
I don't think Hispanics even up a group
is it not that he knows ok ok sorry you
got blacks you got white you got
Italians you got all these people right
Koreans you got we got all these people
but the truth is man economics bind us
all together ok I go down to the grocery
store there's somebody from Korea in
there I'm trading money with that person
ok that that is the exchange you're on a
team your team can be your team that has
the goal they want to go get us to sell
hit a target but part of your team is
also the people you're selling to right
and part of your team is also another
team is the community you live in and
another another team is your church yeah
you know and your family man these are
all teams right and your job and my job
I mean if you want to be all alive all
in the deal your job is to keep all you
need to be a frickin super champion of
all these things right not just one team
rule number 37 embrace every moment how
many of you want to make money
[Music]
pay attention it you can't make more
money if you don't know what we're doing
here
so the first thing is to decide hey am I
in the right place those guys had to
walk in that Stadium last night say hey
we in the right place yeah man ok and
then they probably said man we got a
shot here we got a chance to win a Super
Bowl right you came to work today this
is not a Super Bowl unless you want it
to be but I'm gonna tell you something
if you don't get your life ready right
now if you don't start acting right now
like you're the Super Bowl you're never
gonna make one anyway even when you do
make one I mean if you look at that kid
last night what's his name Nick Nick
ball he's been sitting on the sidelines
for years overlooked for years what you
do right now every day even if you hate
your job I promise you I promise you
this will happen in your life if you
could learn how to embrace every moment
like this is a Super Bowl one day you're
gonna get yourself you're gonna get your
shot but you're not your shot will not
show up if you're not ready because even
if you even if it shows up if you're not
ready you won't be able to see it
rule number 38 have lofty your goals
what advice to have the person did to up
there at their coefficient they're just
up their ambition yeah well you gotta
quit you got to quit saying nonsense
occult stuff like you know I'm happy
where I'm at and we're good we're all
good you know this is just good
everything's good and I'm better off
than somebody and that you got to
comparing yourself to other people
you've got to quit talking like the
middle-class like like you've somehow
arrived because somebody in Iran is
suffering yeah you know you're good
until you're not there's nobody watching
that gives enough money to charity yeah
okay everybody watching should be able
to give a million dollars a year to
charity but you can't you know why you
can't you would if you could
but you can't because you didn't yeah
you didn't produce enough because by the
way it's not your money anyway yeah
somebody else gave you the money
yeah and you pass it on most of you like
I'm really charitable I'm really good
but you never do enough why because you
never had enough yeah and so so because
you didn't produce enough because you
didn't work enough cuz you didn't expand
enough so I would just say to people
look have some loftier goals rule number
39 surround yourself with success so you
know every time I'm having trouble every
time I'm like man I don't think I can
get to where I'm going
I just started looking at the top I
don't look at the bad facts all I do is
I start searching tell me about wealthy
people facts about wealthy people
anything what are they doing what are
they buying it just gets me out of my
problem right it gets me to think bigger
you know the first plane I bought I
bought this plane because I saw other
wealthy people making moves I'm not an
irresponsible person okay like I have
always been a very frugal person but the
frugal was hurting me not helping me
your network is your net worth how rich
you can get has something to do with who
you're hanging with how rich you can
think has something to do with you who
you're hanging with okay how smart you
are has something to do with your
surroundings if you hang out with dumb
people you go end up dumb if you hang
out with junkies you're going to end up
being a junkie you hang out with
criminals I'm not talking about two
people to go to jail I'm talking about
all the people it's your office right
now they cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with creme
crimps you end up being a Crim
if you want to build a network number
one thing commit to building a network a
network by definition is not if you're
building a new it network is not the
people you're already with it's how do I
add people to my network so number one
you got to commit to building a network
number two who do you want in the
network who is it
most of you just go for more people like
you have already in your network I want
new people new characters new
personalities new thinking new ideas
the old adage if you're the smartest
person in the room you in the wrong room
and number three when you start building
this network up and you start meeting
the people okay number two is who do you
want to meet who who you an add to the
Met Network you go 9,000 people in a
room you don't need to meet all 9,000
you need to meet maybe a list of 30 or
40 people who do you want to meet number
three when you meet them focus on them
not on you it shouldn't be here's my
card I'm a car
Proctor this is what I do can I give you
an adjustment it it should be like who
are you how can I help you what are you
doing where do you live okay
what projects are you working on how can
I help you rule 40 you can do anything
so I was a car salesman when I was 25
years old with an accounting degree I
was the only accounting degree car
salesman in the state of Louisiana I
hated myself for it I'll make it three
grand a month nobody would hire me as an
accountant one out of four jobs in
Louisiana you couldn't get one out of
four people 25% unemployment and I just
said how do I go from three grand to 4
grand that's all I want to know but I
started paying attention ok who can get
me that money I don't have it who's got
it
I needed shoes I needed jeans right I
needed a new shirt I had these white
shirts I'm a car salesman I need a nice
clean crisp white shirts people believe
in me I need some training I don't know
how to talk to people
I hate sales I hate it still hate it
today I've made hundreds of millions of
dollars providing sales of programs to
corporations I hate sales so the fact
that I hated it didn't mean I don't do
it because you're only gonna be paid to
waste your whole life you will never be
paid fairly ever so give up the hope I'm
not being paid fairly bullish you will
never ever be paid fairly you're gonna
be underpaid most of your life and then
one day if you're lucky you'll be
overpaid I'm gonna tell you someone I
made four grand that was the most
important money that I've ever made in
my entire life no money has ever made me
happier than that thousand dollars
because that thousand dollars made me
realize I can do anything
rule number 41 be courageous
how many heard the same avoid takes
money too that's not true it takes
courage to make money it takes courage
to make money not money
that's why immigrants come to America
and make money they came with nothing
except what courage you lost your
courage when you got in the middle class
you trade your courage I'm doing good
you think you're doing good to the
brains Falls rule number 42 be
unreasonable the thing that I do at my
company that is very unusual is that we
are completely unreasonable without
reason without we don't use yes I'm
logical okay yes I'm a sane person but
when it comes to achieving a target we
we do it with like we abandon reason and
logic we don't talk about yeah but we
never start yeah but or no we can't or
we couldn't because or it didn't happen
because any any time you're talking any
time you're making sense of why
something didn't work we don't have the
budget we can't do that because yeah but
we're different you are being reasonable
the great things that have happened on
this planet and continue to happen or
because people are unreasonable they
literally abandon reason and logic they
defy the universe now if you look around
if you're a logical person if you're a
person has to make sense of it
beforehand then spend some time looking
around the universe look at nature look
at all the things that are done everyday
that literally defy gravity defying the
five physics it's all over the place if
you need to be reasonable now in my case
I don't need to be reasonable because
there's enough cases of super successful
people doing things that are amazing
whether it was a manufacturing a new
product or whether it was Steve Jobs
coming back to Apple and turning that
company around every day ever you look
at Amazon look what Amazon is done okay
now you look at it you're like dude does
a no-brainer make it make all products
available online now it's a no-brainer
now it's like it's so logical look at
Bill Crow velcro is like god I should
have thought of that
see but beforehand it was completely out
of reason that you could stick things
together
because they scratch one another you
understand what I'm saying so look this
is what I want you to try try this in
your life it's gonna be very difficult
it's one of the most difficult things I
do is being unreasonable because all the
people I'm surrounded by are trying to
make sense of why they can't do
something quit making sense of why you
can't do something and become
unreasonable until you do do something
rule number 43 show up what are you
gonna do when you wake up and you feel
lost you feel less than you feel you
feel a sense of either depression or
despair and no direction what I do is
this I show up I show up man buddy mine
told me when I was super low point in my
life he said a man show up even if your
life's if your eyes are bleeding and
your life is low show up anyway show up
rule number 44
think big bigger is better how many of
you agree with this
okay if you can live on 900 grand the
only people that won't go to 9 million
are the people that are selfish
unselfish people grow their businesses
selfish people don't okay if you're
taking notes if you're gonna walk away
with something today I'm talking to the
able people here give me the name of a
great company that has seven employees
I'm waiting
give me the name of a great company that
doesn't spend a load of money on
advertising who is this company
tell me give me one name one name of any
company that's great this small see see
see you you built a business on a
fantasy right like I'm gonna get a stake
for I'm gonna get a state for I'm gonna
get an all-state company imma imma be an
Allstate guy and I'm gonna make nine
hundred grand a year you're selfish
folks see see what I'm saying about the
selfish person makes what they need the
unselfish person says I'm gonna make
more than I need
rule number 45 work on yourself
I've been lost most of my life literally
the first 45 years of my life the first
probably 51 years of my life first 45
years for sure I was completely lost
and somewhere between 45 and 51 I
started figuring out okay what am i
doing I started sorting my life out I
started getting some started doing some
courses that really really made a
difference in my life I've always been
in a self-improvement my whole life and
but it wasn't until I was about 45 that
I really started discovering information
that could make me more confident me
more sure you know when I was 25 years
old I was a young salesperson and I
didn't like sales and I and I got
educated on how to sell and I became
very very good at it
I started to understand the process the
customer the objections the rebuttal is
how to follow up how to handle the
rejection and the disappointment that
discouraged how to get over but that
didn't help me become more confident in
me as a person as an individual I was
making money by the time I was 31 I had
a couple businesses they were making
money probably had you know three four
hundred thousand dollars saved when I
was thirty 31 years old because I was
trying to make a little money right by
the time I'm 33 I got it probably a
million dollars in a bank I still didn't
feel good about myself
I just nagging nagging like sense of
desperation and sides-- depression
uncertainty a lack of confidence
and when I started working on me
spiritually that's that's when that's
when at 45 46 47 years old that's when
everything changed for me like
everything all the expansion the
confidence the getting out in the world
maybe a little better communicating than
I was doing I'm not perfect at it by any
means now and I started getting more
certainty about Who I am what I am where
I'm going and why I'm here
like if you don't figure those things
out no amount of money no amount of
money in the world will will fill you up
note the private planes won't the fancy
cars you have to know where you're going
rule number 46 build the team how do you
do this I started with one employee
his name was grant cardone I knew him
and so I hired him right he passed a
drug test I believed in him and for 15
years
I was one guy and then one day I woke up
a guy actually I mentor of mine said
look you can't scale with just yourself
you got to start building a business
here you're gonna have a real business
you need employees you need people you
need to be willing to hire people and
I'm like man man I'm scared they cost
money he's like not making sales one two
or these empty desk that's what's - okay
that's what's costing you money staying
small is costing you money all this cost
money
I have failures here I have
disappointments I have discouragements I
have people that work here for a little
while and I quit but you're not gonna
get big by yourself
rule number 47 don't rest on your
laurels if you asked me to coach your
business I'm not gonna think about how
to hold on to what you did last year
that's what most people right now are
thinking here in March in January you
were like there's gonna be a great year
by March you're like man I just want to
do what we did last year if we just
you're starting to make sense you're
becoming reasonable okay I'm telling you
that because this is what your people do
- okay your people the people that you
hire they make sense of how to make 40 a
grand a year and if you have people in
your company they're trying to make
sense of how to make 48 grand a year you
got a company that's gonna die toys-r-us
fall bankruptcy this week I Heart Radio
the biggest radio station in the world
filed for bankruptcy in this week
there's going to be massive disruption
in the marketplace why because these
companies thought about they kept they
kept having trophies about what they had
rather than what would what they could
get who's got money who's qualified to
buy how can I get their attention how
can I tell them what I want from them
okay
how fast can I get to the marketplace
fast speed is the new big rule number 48
do more you can do more you can do more
than you ever imagined I was broke at 25
years old
broke okay every two years I get one of
these cars the people at rolls-royce
like like I want to send you another one
of those cars okay how you want it how
do you want to address what color you
want it that gets crazy it's crazy the
life I'm living right now we did a we
did a conference it was ten thousand
people in the room and another ten
thousand people in line all of them paid
to be there I remember when I couldn't
get two people to show up at a party in
high school because I was so disliked
you can do more than you think you can
it's my message to you today you will
live longer than you think I promise you
okay you can do more than you think you
again
rule number 49 go on the offense
your parents were looking for 40 grand
it doesn't pay for anything today so you
need to change the way you think how
many of you were taught when you ate
when mama brought you a meal she said
this she brought you the meal threw it
on the plate and said eat it all how
many were told that you know what she
was trying to tell you don't waste money
that's what she was trying to say what
she was really saying is I don't know
how to make more money she was really
saying there's a shortage of money eat
it all there's people in China starving
how many got that message every day how
many of you when you walked out of your
bedroom your mama said turn off those
lights what was she telling you I don't
know how to get new money that's what
she was telling you my dad died when I
was 10 my mom was left to bring up five
kids okay and those are the messages I
got every day the same message was this
contract get small back up protect
yourself I can't win anything like this
I cannot succeed for my family like this
I do not want my kids to see me like
this I want them I want my kids to see
me on attack right confidence in the
marketplace how do you get confidence
you read man you guys got to read okay
the app the average American reads less
than one book a year half those books
are romance novels
now I don't have my books with me today
but we I've written four books since
2009 for this new economy I wrote those
books for me I didn't write them for
other people I did not write them to get
known I wrote those books because I was
trying to figure out how do I get myself
out of this problem
and rule number 50 the last home before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
I've been putting this off as long as I
can this whole you know
this whole thing there's no burnout I'm
starting to wonder maybe there's some
burnout because I've been feeling tired
maybe beat up a dragon I'm starting to
really question some of the stuff I've
been telling you guys for a long time
about the whole 10x everything go to the
next level freaking you could do more
it's about time it's been a long time
coming I've been doing a lot of
reflecting about it saying hey I need to
tell people I think I've been wrong with
this thing I am a candle in the wind
you know you can burn out it's not worth
all the work
hold - next thing all you guys about to
10x rule and you like I gotta go 10x
and I don't know man the whole TARDIS in
the hair you know just showing up and
telling that they can rethinking the
whole deal and for those of you gonna
follow me for a long time jumping on
that bandwagon telling you gotta shut it
down or shutting down okay taking a
break of social media taking a break on
all the interviews and taking a break on
all the podcasts get off these freaking
80 100 hour weeks grind for the money
sell them a plane get rid of the car
scaling down everything everything you
get rid of all my debt I'm just going
back to freaking old school take it easy
a full day in fact I tell you what I'm
gonna do let me tell you what I'm gonna
do first of all I'm getting a new car
I'm ordering a damn thing today it's
gonna be if you give with your
permission it's gonna be white oh damn I
can't open it up it's gonna be white I'm
gonna I'm gonna have it white I'm gonna
have it white on white with red piping
all over the place red dashboards go
blow up it's so scream when I go up
getting a new plane I'm not getting a
new freaking I'm gonna go from 9
passengers to like 13 or 14 it's gonna
be sick
now I've got a really special grant
cardone bonus clip on how to discipline
yourself but before that you've come a
long way you've watched this entire
video I want to know one what do you
think of this format we took the 50
rules that we've done over five volumes
and smoosh them into one video for you
let me know what you think and - from
all of this that you've learned from
grant what is the single most important
lesson that you're going to apply
somehow to your life or your business
leave it down in the comments below when
you write it down you're much more
likely to actually do it so leave in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
control how do you discipline that he
struck monitoring what you're saying to
yourself I can't find the right girl I
can't find the right guy marriage is
hard I'm broke I'm poor it's gonna be
hard if you don't change your mind you
gotta change the way you think and a way
to change the way you think first of all
the one way is to start discipline
yourself catch yourself every time you
say I don't have time say hey I create
time every time you say I know have
money I create money literally like
talking to yourself hey I am a
millionaire so if you're broke right now
quit say and I am broke and start saying
what you want where are you going
it's not complicated you want to get
rich I got rich you want to get rich you
can nothing and no one's got that you
can do that but the information the most
important work ever if you have to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple so it would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]